now this week looks then set to be a key
one for the Labour leadership the party
is under pressure to clarify its
position on air strikes in Syria ahead
of a votes potentially as early as
Wednesday well the Shadow Chancellor
John McDonald has described it as a
matter of moral conscience suggesting
the boat should be a free one and of
course there's the matter of Chairman
Mao's little red book maybe a bit more
about that later John McDonald joins me
now as you can see very good morning to
you mr. McDonald free boat then you
stick by that this is a matter of
conscience and Labour MPs should be able
to vote accordingly without being forced
by the leadership I think all MPs should
be put in that position I hope David
Cameron will allow his members have a
free vote as well I've held that
position now for I've been in 18 years
all that time I've been on the basis
that this is about party politics and it
should be down to the individual MP
consulting his constituency obviously
and coming forward with his or her view
on the well the safety is his or her own
constituents on the country at large is
why didn't Jeremy Corbyn say that this
morning you must have talked to him
about this yes Amanda you know what
white painted into a corner on this so
not be you've got to get used to this in
the media about the new politics within
the Labour Party what jeremy has done is
set out his own view about this your own
bombing but also is made it clear the
party members are Shadow Cabinet our
national executive committee our
parliamentary Labour Party will all have
a view of expressing their views he's
undertook a consultation is closing that
consultation by the end of today and
then he'll make a decision and recommend
that to the Shadow Cabinet take it to
the shadow parents the leaders decision
in the end he's I'm hoping he's taken my
view into account just as much as
anybody else's and I'm hoping I say this
again I'm asking David Cameron to do the
same thing as well and have a free vote
across the house ok but what is mr
corbyn up to then with this saying he'll
consult again he's already consulted
with the membership and he mentioned
this morning about the scale of the
mandate he has from Labour members and
supporters is he trying to intimidate
MPs no of course not not at all you've
got to get used to our new processes
democracy within our party everyone
should have a say and that's where he's
making sure they cannot representative
democracy yes the MPS once the MPs are
elected they take it is not the half of
their constituents and they don't
normally
well there's a nasal are democracies let
me finish we're trying to get a new
politics where people can have their say
so when MPs come to their decisions
they're informed of the views expressed
by party members their constituents and
others and what Jeremy is doing is using
all the new technological methods of
social media consultations making sure
people have their say and we can then
take those into account we've had from
his email that went out on think late
Friday night we've had 70,000 and more
responses already expressing their views
about the situation on the bombing and I
think also on the issue around the free
vote or not so he'll come to a decision
on that basis and that all those views
will be taking it okay so not not
intimidate but just describing that
process to me as you have mr. McDonald
you're talking about putting pressure
more MPs from below well as well because
you know it's something you're not with
the membership to sorry term you're not
pressure on their MP you're not
listening you're mistaking dialogue and
consultation for the old politics of
lobbying and pressure that isn't what
we're about anymore we're allowing
people to express their views and what
that means is MP is really before your
challenge I mean within that would you
like some MPs to change their minds MP
so perhaps haven't consulted as widely
as they have done with their
consignments with their members of their
local parties would who are thinking of
voting along with mr. Cameron's
recommendation would you like them to
change their minds so it's interesting
people the bulk of people I've spoken to
and actually keeping their minds open
and I read this morning David Davis is
the Conservative MP former conservative
Home Secretary I read his article which
I thought was extremely considered now
he's come down against bombing by the
looks of it but he's putting some really
clear questions I think that still need
to be addressed in the debate so I think
on a cross-party base I want a consensus
now sir Commons if we can lift this
above party politics allow MPs to come
to a view on the base of their
conscience I think it was we get so much
better decisions in that way but you
haven't changed your views though
because you know we remember back to
well remember your your conference when
you set as you described in some pretty
stringent conditions to apply if there
were to be any British military action
in Syria have they all been met I mean
the key one is of course authorization
from the United Nations humanitarian
assistance for refugees there's a lot of
that going on a bombing is thar
it's only that's what we hear from the
Prime Minister and international
diplomatic well let which are ongoing at
the moment let me just quote back David
Davis on his article what he's saying is
that he's not convinced there's either
military plan or a long-term political
solution thats been planned by the Prime
Minister as well and I agree with that i
think the prime minister actually has
come forward with proposals which i
think many people are skeptical about
and actually might worsen the situation
so i i'm i'm opposed to the bombing
because i know the I grens been brought
forward that this will be very clinical
very precise etc I'm concerned that any
collateral damage will be used by Isis
as a recruitment tool to be frank and i
think it will possibly in dangerous even
more i would like us to do two things
concentrate on our own security abroad
at home and then abroad what we need to
do is be the broker of a political
solution in the region i think the
regional powers will have to solve this
they've got to step up to the plate and
i think we've got to put that on the
agenda now and the Vienna talks and that
that does mean exactly as we did in Iraq
actually when the Sunni tribes turned on
al Qaeda and defeated them that was the
most effective way of actually resolving
the situation ok and in terms of the
what's going on in Parliament there are
those that are now saying you are you
and Jeremy Corbyn are trying to to muddy
the waters we know the prime minister
position on a vote he wants to know he's
going to win it and he wants to know the
positions of your party and he wants to
know he's got enough of his own MPs as
you describe who will vote with him are
you trying to put enough doubt in the
Prime Minister's mind here that he
actually won't hold a vote at all no I
think the Prime Minister needs to think
very very carefully about all these
issues that have been raised not just by
Labour MPs but by conservative MPs as
well it's not about sowing doubt is
actually honestly expressing one's
judgment I've been in part as I said for
18 years I've SAT there when decisions
have been made to send our young men and
women to war and some of them have come
back unfortunately maimed and killed I
think it's most serious decision and
member of parliament can make and I
think the Prime Minister needs to take
account the real problems that a number
of MPs have got with this promotion of a
bombing campaign which many ways think
will be counterproductive and you think
it could be counterproductive in the
sense that it could lead to terror
attacks on the streets of Britain we're
in we're already under threat let's be
clear about that that's why I think
I support the government's investment
increased security and I'm glad we
change the Chancellor's mind with regard
to cutting the police but the reality is
we're not fighting a conventional war
here this isn't like the Second World
War where you fight on a battlefield you
defeat the enemy they sign a peace
treaty and go away we're fighting yes a
bit of a traditional campaign on a
battlefield but I think also we're
fighting a terrorist campaign and
terrorism terrorism works by the actual
perpetrators convincing others they're
the victims and rhinology I mean the
question is about making yourself a
target as your colleague Ken Livingstone
said on Thursday when it came to the the
awful barbarity of 77 and all the people
that died in London on that day that he
saw that as a direct consequence of
Britain's involvement in the invasion of
Iraq think similar things could flow
from the into the lesson Syria the
lessons we've got to learn whatever
action we take we mustn't allow the
action to be used by Isis as a
recruitment tool to radicalize people
within our own community and across
Europe so we have to be really careful
on what we do but thinking Livingston's
right well I think there's a grain of
truth in the fact that well if we do
anything that enables I system to have
this narrative that this is a crusader
invasion or attack between Christians
against Muslims it's nothing of the sort
what we're tackling here is a murderous
group but we've got to be sophisticated
in the way we do that and nothing we do
shall be allowed to be used by them to
recruit to their terrorist okay so not a
direct causal link but it could add to
that narrative I worry is that they will
use it in that way and I think what
we've got to do is be much more
sophisticated now learn the lessons of
Iraq certainly and in that way we can I
think we can prevent them radicalizing
our youth and using this as a tool to
recruit there is another way for its
well and you've talked about the
diplomacy and we know about you know
your your discussions and contacts with
the ir ancient vein over the years and
ultimately it was talks led to that
conflict at least been been stopped and
progress being made there do you think
we may come to a situation where
elements of Islamic state could hold
discussions with us I can't see it
because they're I can't sit with this
group
because they're they seem to have a or
they call the death cult they seem to be
so ideologically opposed to everything
that we stand for i can't see those
negotiations taking place with a group
like this i I don't think that's
possible but as in Iraq what happened
was is that the Sunni tribes clans
turned on al-qaeda we've got to work on
those people who are not fighting
against them on the ground at the moment
and may be given them tacit support can
I say also the point that Jeremy Corbyn
raised time and time again the House of
Commons is absolutely key as well we've
got to stop the supply of weapons and
also stop them selling oil to
surrounding powers basically and I think
there's one way of doing that is bombing
the tankers and the oil in place well
quite quite the reverse actually i think
the bombing then cause collateral damage
then they used to recruit in the wide
arab region there's a simple question
here is all about socialist solidarity
isn't there president Hollande calling
for our help yes I thought mark rylance
answered that the actor answer that very
clearly st an interview i thought was
quite clever response we said if your
friend is in a fight and then he calls
upon you to get in that vice sometimes
it's best to say actually there's a
better way of resolving this so I'm not
sure whether immediate response in terms
of bombing is the right way forward I
think what we should be doing is using
our skills that we've demonstrated in
Northern Ireland to be honest about how
you arrived at a peaceful situation well
and a lot of a can but you mentioned
mark rylance speaking at the rally s
that he also talked about talking to
Islamic state well I don't think that's
feasible I think that I don't think
that's feasible with this group but I
actually do think if we bring the
regional powers together within their
area we can get them to step up to the
plate a lot of the Sunni regimes now
just backed off because we're there the
more we intervened them the less they
perform their responsibilities okay one
of us you've got to ask you about the
the Autumn Statement we got that clip
again when you must have thought it was
a terribly good wheeze to to wave a
little bit red book around at the
chancel it's just have a look at that
moment see what you think of it now I
brought him a long mouths little red
book
any further
let me for this
approaches this
behave we must learn to do economic work
from all who know how no matter who they
are we must have seen them as teachers
learning from them respectfully and
conscientiously but we must not to
pretend to know what we do not know I
thought it would come in handy for him
in his new noises have you seen that
back since Wednesday with plenty times
don't worry I can see sorry but I mean
what was going through your mind you
would set backfired no don't think it
did backfire onto the media but don't
think back friday master general public
it's interested in the amount of emails
are being having Eva's people stopping
on with streets and actually it made a
good point the point I was trying to get
across which we wouldn't be talking
about if I hadn't done that is I'm
really worried about the asset sales the
Office of Budget Responsibility has said
that the government can only bring down
its debt as a result these asset sales
that are going on and I'm worried for
example they brought 45 billion pounds
worth of asset sales air traffic control
is now being sold I'm worried about how
much of our assets are being sold off
it's no longer the family silver this is
the furniture and it's being sold off to
foreign states and I find that really
worrying both in terms of particularly
strategic resources like the air traffic
control but also it's affecting our
balance of payments now is sold off so
much that income has been sucked out of
our economies not think you don't think
waving you know the Communist Manifesto
like that around socialist yourself
rather took that point where rather
doubt that generally would not look you
would usually the Shadow Chancellor
speech sinks beneath the waves with it
about half an hour him or making it you
would not be talking about if I hadn't
done that should I say something else as
well I find it quite ironic as well that
actually George Osborne is going around
China selling off our assets and he's
dealing with a regime that actually is
abusing human rights at the same time
I've been campaigning against the
invasion of Tibet or the oppression of
the Tibetan people by China they don't
seem to be raising any human rights
issues so this has allowed me to do two
things expose the asset sales about
going on expose the implications of that
us selling our assets abroad to foreign
powers in addition to that start raising
human rights issues in China to do you
ever feel that you and Jeremy Corbyn are
reaching the end of the road I mean is
all this is all this getting to do you
think you are gonna transfer
the exchange s yeah look we I think what
we're doing here is we're opening up
politics and actually as a result of
that we're becoming stronger because
we're engagement more and more people
and I don't be too critical but the
media are almost in a separate bubble
and when you get into a situation now
where people are turning off from
reading papers sometimes I had to say
watching TV as well because it doesn't
reflect their lives what we're doing is
reconnecting people with the political
system and what about the old and
by-election you think the wheels might
come off the bus there and that might
have implications for your continued
tenure no I was there yesterday
canvassing in the pouring rain and the
response on the door so that was pretty
good fantastic candidate in Jim McMahon
local boy really knows his constituency
people respect him a lot it's going to
be it depends on the weather on the day
to December by-elections are no choice
for low turnout so you can or whatever
the result no resignations oh no no it's
all know we go on but I think we're
going from strength to strength okay
well shadow chancellor could see thank
you very much indeed John McDonald there
and it should be said about the olin
by-election there's a full list of
candidates on our website there